∼♪（ソフトバンクの音楽）
…おや？このＢＧＭは
こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
皆さんスマートフォン何使ってますか？
今回はですねソフトバンクさんから発売されている
こちらXperia™XZ1を紹介しようと思います
これ…
何がすごいかと言いますと
とりあえずカメラがめちゃくちゃきれいです！
あと、音がめちゃくちゃ良い
そして！
というもうとてもハイスペックなスマートフォンに
なっているんですけども
いろんな機能があるんですけどもその中でも今回は
という機能を使ってみようと思います！
3Ⅾクリエイターとは人の顔や物を
3Ⅾで撮影することができる機能のことです
カズさんもこのエクスペディアの3Ⅾクリエイターの機能を使って
お父さんを3Ⅾ化してたんですけども
今日は実際にこのエクスペディアの
3Ⅾ機能を使って
僕を…
3Ⅾフィギュアにしてみようと思います！
昔だとその3Ⅾフィギュアって
むずかしそうなイメージがあったんですけど
今だともうスマホで出来ちゃうという時代に
なってきました
というわけで早速3Ⅾクリエイターの機能を使って
3Ⅾフィギュアの撮影をしていこうと
思うんですけども
なんかすごい簡単みたいなので
もうちゃちゃっとやっていきたいと思います！
では行こう！！
はい！というわけで無事
3Ⅾの撮影が終了しました！
5種類ぐらいいろんな顔のレパートリーとったんで
ちょっと見ていきましょう
はいじゃあ早速どんなのが取れたか見ていきましょう
例えばこれとか
まあパッと見は普通の絵なんですけども
これが実はもう3Ⅾになってます
ほら
ｗｗｗ
すごいっすねー
ﾊﾊﾊﾊwwww
でこれ僕は自分の顔で撮ったんですけど
ものとかも3Ⅾで撮影できることが可能でございます！
わぁーすごいなー
すごい舌まで舌もちゃんと出てる
ていう感じでですね
結構なクオリティの
3Ⅾ画像が撮ることが可能です！
はいでは3Ⅾ撮影した写真を
えー早速3Ⅾフィギュアとして
注文していきましょう！
じゃこの子を3Ⅾフィギュアにしていきましょう
3Ⅾプリントをしてモデルのフィギュアを出力する
で、モデルをアップロードします
はい
これで今アップロード中です
よしきた！
種類を選択
おお
肩までの部分しかないんですけども
体の部分をどれにするかっていうのが
決められるみたいです
色々ありますねー
じゃあとりあえず
フォーマル・ドレスフィギュアにしますか
はい
わすげーこんなかにもいろいろあるんだ
ウェディングドレスにしましょっか
はい
はい、というわけで無事残りのフィギュアの
えー注文も無事終了したので
しばらく3Ⅾフィギュア完成するまで
お待ちを！
ﾊｯwwこれか！
では開けていきましょう！
え待って怖い怖い怖い
1人目はこれか
はい！
ﾊﾊﾊﾊｯwwちょっとww
すげーなー
頭の形がすごいそっくりなんすよね
え待って待って待ってえ待ってこの感じで
あと4つくんのか
おー次は小さいな
はい！
ﾌﾞﾌﾞﾌﾞｩwww
いやよくできてますよ
よくできてますけど
俺の顔がおかしいんだと思います多分
3つ目
はい！
すげーな凹凸がすげーリアルなんだよな
4つ目いきます！
4つ目も小さいな
はい！
お、お、お
www
すげーでも似てるわー
完全に俺だー
さあラスト1つ！
これ多分サイズ的に大きめだと思います
せーの
はい！
wwww
はい、というわけで
エクスペリアを使って
こうやって3Ⅾフィギュアを作ることもできます！
トイレに置いておきます
（ﾆﾔﾘ）
wwwwww
ﾊﾊﾊﾊwww
よし
ちょっと笑ってくれました☆
で今回なんと!!
エクスペリアの3Ⅾクリエイターで作った
僕のフィギュアを！
プレゼントしちゃいまーーす！！
ﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁ
ほしいよね!（威圧）
詳しくはソフトバンクさんの公式ツイッターの方を
確認してみてください！
いやまじ普通にリアルですからね
そしてこの3Ⅾクリエイターですね
ほかの楽しみ方もいっぱいあるみたいです
はいこういう感じでですね
ARで遊ぶこともできます
すごいちゃんとついてくる
わーすごい
本当に机の上にいるみたい
ていう遊び方もできます！
Xperia™XZ1
いろんな楽しみ方があると思うんですけども
今回の僕のテーマはこちら！！
3Ⅾクリエイターでした
なかなか3Ⅾフィギュアってこう
一般の人が手が出せないようなイメージがあったんですけども
今回このXperia™XZ1で
すごい３Ⅾっていうものが身近に感じることができました！
結構ビビりましたw
というわけで今回はこの時代の最先端
Xperia™XZ1とのタイアップでした
ぜひ動画の概要欄からチェックしてみてください！
じゃあな！！
お父さんも
ワン！
∼♪（エンディング）
また見てね!!